Now I will read a brief story of Kurt Vonnegut Jr., called Harrison Bergeron.
The year was 2081 and finally everyone was equal.
They were equal not only to God and the laws. They were equal in every respect.
No one was smarter than anybody else. Nobody looked better than anyone else. Nobody was stronger and faster than anyone else.
All this equality was due to the 211th, 212st and 213st amendments to the Constitution,
and the tireless vigilance of the United States' General Disruptors.
However, some things in life were not quite right.
April, for example, was still causing people to go mad because spring is not coming yet.
It was in this rainy month that the chief troubled people took the fourteen-year-old son of George and Hazel Bergeron, Harrison.
The event was tragic, no doubt, but George and Hazel could not think much of it about it.
Hazel possessed a normal average intelligence, which meant that she could think of nothing but brief outbursts.
And George, whose intelligence was far above average, had a little radio in his ear for mental interference.
The law obliged him to wear it all the time.
It was set on the wave of the government transmitter,
who every twenty seconds sent a sharp sound that would prevent people like George from taking advantage of his mind.
George and Hazel watched TV.
Hazel's cheeks were tears, but she did not remember why they were.
The ballerinas were visible on the TV screen.
A bell rang in George's head.
His thoughts ran panicky, like thieves from an alarm system.
"It was a nice dance," Hazel said. - Who we just saw.
- Mm? George asked.
"This dance," Hazel repeated. - It was nice.
"Ah," George nodded.
He tried to think a little about the ballerinas.
In fact, they were not particularly good - no better than anyone else in their place.
They were loaded with weights of scales and lead spheres, and their faces were masked,
so that no one could see a gentle gesture or a beautiful face,
not to feel like something the cat has brought from the street.
Through his mind, the belly thought that ballerins might not have artificial difficulties,
but he could not get too far in his mind because the next bell interrupted.
George was startled. Two of the eight baler men were also startled.
Hazel noticed his rapping.
Since she had no mental difficulty, she had to ask George what the last sound was.
"It sounded as if someone hit a bottle of milk with a hammer," he replied.
"It must be very interesting to hear all these sounds," Hazel said with a slight envy. - All the things they think ...
"Hmm," George said.
"But if I were a General Difficult, did you know what I was going to do?" Hazel asked.
It was very much like the General Difficult - a woman named Diana Moon Glamphers.
"If I were Diana Moon Glammers, I would have a bell ringing on Sunday. Something like a tribute to religion.
"If it's just a bell ringing," George remarked, "I can think.
"Maybe I would have done it very loud," Hazel decided. "It seems to me that a good General Difficult would have come out of me.
"Not better than anyone else.
- Who knows better than I mean "normal"?
"That's right," George nodded.
He began to think of his abnormal son, who was now in jail, about Harrison,
but twenty-one tomato salutes echoed in his head and put an end to it.
- Ow! Hazel exclaimed. "It was great, was not it?"
It was so great that George was pale and trembling. His red eyes filled with tears.
Two of the eight ballerinas in the studio collapsed on the floor and caught on the temples.
"Suddenly he got so tired," Hazel said.
"Why do not you stretch on the couch?" So you can put your weight on the pillow, dear.
He meant the pouch bag with twenty pounds of lead shot locked by a lock on his neck.
"Go and hold her, I do not mind for a while not being equal to me.
George gently lifted the bag to feel her weight.
"It does not hinder me," he said. - I do not pay any attention to it anymore. It has become a part of me.
"You've been tired lately," Hazel said. - Exhausted.
Well, there was a way to drill a hole at the bottom and pull out a little, very little of the balls ...
- Two years in prison and two thousand dollars fine for every ball ... I do not think it's worth it.
"If you could get a little out when you get back from work ... I mean, you do not have to compete with anyone here ... Just sit back.
- If I do, others will do it and just see
we were again in the dark times when everyone competed with everyone else.
You will not like that, do you?
- Not.
- That's it. At the moment people start cheating and circumvent the laws, what do you think will be with the public?
If Hazel had not answered this question, George could not help her, because the sirens turned into his brain again.
"I guess it'll fall apart," she said, shaking her head.
- What? George asked with a blank look.
"Society," repeated Hazel. "You just said that?"
- Who knows? George asked.
Suddenly the TV program broke off because of the news.
It was not clear at first what it was about, as the spokesman,
like all other speakers, had difficulty talking.
For a minute and a half, in a state of excitement, he hesitated to say, "Ladies and gentlemen."
He finally gave up and handed the sheet to a ballerina to read it.
"There is nothing," George assured him. - He tried. This is important.
He tried to do the best that the Lord had given him. They have to raise it for trying so hard.
"Ladies and gentlemen," she began to read the ballerina.
She must have been amazingly beautiful because her mask was terrible.
It was not hard to notice that she was the strongest and graceful of all dancers,
because the bag with her weights was as much as for the men of grammar.
She had to apologize for her voice because it was unfair for a woman to use such a voice.
Her voice was a warm, bright, timely melody.
"Excuse me," said the ballerina, making his voice absolutely uncompetitive.
"Harrison Bergeron, fourteen," she cried unbearably,
- has just escaped from prison, where he was arrested on suspicion of a conspiracy to overthrow the government.
He is a genius, an athlete, inadequate, and should be regarded as extremely dangerous.
A police photograph of Harrison Bergeron appeared on the screen - down with his head, then sideways, back down with his head, then up with his right hand.
The picture showed its height, compared with the wall, measured in meters and centimeters, at the back - it was two meters high.
The rest of his appearance was carnival and hardware. No one has ever carried heavier and bulkier weights.
He was growing faster than the General Difficult people were able to invent new ones.
Instead of a small receiver in his ear, he had huge headphones and glasses with thick, wavy magnifying glasses.
These glasses should not only hinder him from seeing, but also cause him severe headaches.
His body was hung on metallic pieces.
Normally, in the stumbling blocks of strong people, there was some kind of symmetry, some sort of military order,
but Harrison looked like a rolling stock of secondary raw materials.
In the race of life, he was carrying a hundred and fifty pounds on himself.
In order to spoil his good looks, people of the General Difficulty had made him put a red rubber ball instead of a nose,
to shave his eyebrows and cover his flat white teeth with chaotic black crowns.
"If you see this boy," he continued reading the ballerina, "do not, repeat, do not try to make a reasonable conversation with him.
There was a scream, as if someone had been knocking a door off her hinges.
There were shouts and desperate shouts from the TV.
Harrison Bergeron's picture rocked on the screen as if dancing in the rhythm of an earthquake.
George Bergeron correctly identified what this earthquake was,
because his own home was repeatedly shaken by the same devastating rhythm.
- God! He exclaimed. "It must be Harrison!"
The thought was instantly driven from his head by the sound of a car crash.
When she managed to open her eyes again, Harrison's picture had disappeared from the screen.
It was the real, living Harrison.
A screaming, enormous and reminiscent patrolman, he swayed in the middle of the studio.
The handle from the broken door was still in his hand.
Ballerins, technicians, musicians and speakers had fallen on their knees in anticipation of death.
- I'm the Emperor! "Harrison roared.
- Do you hear? I am the Emperor! Everyone should do what I say right away!
He thumped his feet and the studio shook.
"Even as I stand before you now - crippled, wretched, sick," he continued to roar,
- I am the greatest ruler of all who have ever been born!
Now look at what I can become!
Harrison ripped his weight straps as if they were wet toilet paper, and they were guaranteed to withstand three hundred pounds.
The pieces of old iron screamed on the floor.
He pushes his fingers under the metal pad of the padlock, holding the gear on his head. She broke her like a match.
Then he pushed the glasses and the headphones into the wall.
He removed the rubber nose and a man emerged on the screen, who could carry out awe-inspiring Tor - the god of storms.
"And now I will choose my Empress! He said, looking down at the fearful men.
- Let the first woman, who dares to stand on her feet, come to me to take her partner and her throne!
It was only a moment later, then one of the ballerinas rose and swayed like a shallow willow.
Harrison pulled the mental retarder from her ear, broke the physical obstacles with amazing ease.
At last he removed the mask. She was dazzlingly beautiful.
"Now," Harrison continued, and took her hand, "we will show people what the meaning of the word" dance "is.
- Music! He commanded.
The musicians crawled to their chairs, and Harrison released them from their weights.
"Play as much as you can," he ordered, "and I'll make you barons, dukes and counts!
The music started. At first it was normal - cheap, dull, insincere.
But Harrison grabbed two musicians from their seats, turned them into the air as conductors and sang the music they wanted to play.
Then he threw them into their chairs.
The orchestra played again, this time much better.
For some time Harrison and his Empress just listened -
- grim, as if they were synchronizing their hearts with the rhythm.
They then moved their center of gravity to their toes.
Harrison put his huge hands on the thin cross of the girl,
giving him the opportunity to test the weightlessness that would soon be theirs.
Then they were carried in the air, filled with joy and beauty.
They have abandoned not only the laws of men, but also the laws of gravity and movement.
They wore, swirled, swam, flew, crouched. They were jumping like deer on the Moon.
The ceiling of the studio was ten meters tall, but with each jump they approached him.
Obviously, their purpose was to kiss the ceiling. They kissed him.
They then neutralized the operation of gravity law
and stayed a few inches below the ceiling where they kissed for a long, long time.
Then Diana Moon Glampres, the general handicapped, armed with a two-piece hunting rifle of tenth caliber, entered the studio.
He shot twice and the Emperor and his Empress died before they fell to the floor.
Diana Moon Glamphers loaded the rifle again.
He pointed it to the musicians and told them he gave them ten seconds to put their weight.
At that moment, the Bergesson family's TV set burned.
Hazel turned to George to mark the fact.
But George had gone to the kitchen to get a beer box.
He returned with the beer and stopped for a moment until the signal from the transmitter came to a halt. Then he sat down again.
- You crying? He asked Hazel. "Ah," she nodded.
- Why?
- I forgot. For something on TV ... really sad.
- What was it?
- Everything is so confused in my head ...
"Forget the sad things," George advised.
"I always forget them," Hazel said.
"Good girl," he nodded, startled.
There were shots in his head.
- God! You know the last one was great! Hazel looked at him.
- Tell him again.
- God! You know the last one was great!
"Harrison Bergeron" is the copyright of Kurt Vonnegut Jr, 1961. [